gran noche para el cine latinoamericano
en la entrega de premios del festival de
cine de San Sebastián desde el público
hasta el Jurado premiaron al cine del
continente con cinco de los 14 premios
principales del certamen Empezando por
el del público que premió a Argentina
1985 de Santiago mitre una película
inspirada en el juicio a las juntas
proceso contra el órgano militar de la
dictadura Argentina para el productor
del filme recibir el premio del público
para una película que trata sobre la
defensa de la Democracia resulta
doblemente hermoso el premio Horizonte
es a la mejor cinta latinoamericana fue
para tengo sueños eléctricos de
Valentina maurel la costarricense en su
discurso pidió que este premio sirva
para que el presidente Rodrigo Chávez
reconsidere los recortes al presupuesto
de cultura en su país la joven Argentina
por su parte Renata lerman con tan solo
12 años Recibió la concha de plata a la
mejor interpretación de reparto y
Argentina también se llevó el premio del
Jurado a la mejor fotografía que recibió
Manuel abramo la película porno
melancolía pero la corona del festival
la concha de oro La Recibió la película
colombiana Los reyes del mundo de la
directora Laura Mora es la primera vez
en la 70 ediciones que una cinta
colombiana se lleva el gran premio Y el
tercer año consecutivo en el que gana un
filme dirigido por una mujer en su
cuenta de Twitter celebran que para los
reyes del mundo esto ha sido un viaje en
busca de la tierra prometida que no
podría acabar mejor